der verein ist der horror vorbei für
weitere kommen demnächst gegen kaution
auf freien fuß doch achte 13
inhaftierten kegelbrüder müssen weiter
auf mallorca in u-haft sitzen ja anders
als der am abend freigelassene konnten
sie den haftrichter offenbar nicht von
ihrer unschuld überzeugen
die deutschen kegelbrüder aus dem male
knast hier werden sie dem haftrichter
vorgeführt nach 13 langen tagen hinter
gittern dann am späten abend die erste
positive nachricht nach knallharten
einzel verhören im justizpalast von
palma hat der spanische
untersuchungsrichter angeordnet einer
der 13 kegelbrüder aus münster kommt
sofort frei vier weitere sollen nach
zahlung einer kaution in höhe von 12.000
euro folgen die anderen acht bleiben
vorerst im knast obendrauf dieser hammer
beschluss eine sogenannte solidarhaftung
in höhe von 500.000 euro gegen alle
beschuldigten diese wird wirksam sobald
es zu einer verurteilung kommt nach wie
vor gilt sollte es zum prozess gegen die
männer kommen drohen allen zwischen 25
jahren haft nur der jetzt freigekommene
male urlauber konnte glaubhaft
versichern er stand zum tatzeitpunkt
unter der dusche den anderen mit einer
kaution belegten kegel kollegen konnte
der richter immerhin nicht mehr genügend
vergehen anhaften wegen der dürftigen
beweislast kann er sie nun nicht weiter
im knast schmoren lassen den
beteuerungen der anderen kegelbrüder sie
hätten das feuer nicht gelegt schenkte
der richter offenbar weiterhin wenig
glauben der vorwurf gegen sie wiegt
schwer betrunken sollen die mitglieder
des münsteraner kegelvereins
zigarettenkippen von ihrem hotelbalkon
geschnippt und so das schiff dach der
weinort bar entzündet haben unmittelbar
nach den löscharbeiten werden die männer
festgenommen seitdem sitzen sie in
spanien in u haft obwohl es zweifel an
den tatvorwürfen gibt so sagte eine
augenzeugin zu bild die kegelbrüder
hätten auf einem anderen balkon gefeiert
als von der polizei behauptet und
whatsapp botschaften von ihnen legen nah
dass sie sogar zu helfen versuchten nach
dem das feuer ausgebrochen war bei den
vernehmungen am donnerstag zeigten sie
sich kooperativ bestritten jedoch die
vorwürfe
ihrer schilderung nach bemerkten sie das
feuer und ging nur auf die balkone um zu
sehen was los war sie hätten dann auch
den feueralarm ausgelöst